well what's going on with the dudes man
what do you got what do you got for us
look what are you talking about guys
being sterilized or what well you know
there's there's a a huge decline in uh
sperm in reproductive rates in IQ in
people's Health there's a huge increase
of uh people being fat there's a huge
increase of people not being healthy
there's a huge increase of respiratory
diseases and heart ailments that have
been dramatically increasing all over
the world and you know it's fair to say
that there has been something happening
that has utterly devastated and
destroyed the Modern Men and whether you
look at and a family-friendly show here
but but specifically if you look at you
know reproductive organs they've been
shrinking
um I don't know if I could say uh the
thing I want to say that the the the
size between the two private parts is
also shrinking which which you know
which one yes yes yes there's a lot of
things chemically happening right now A
lot of people are blaming plastic Fort
as Plastics have been found in people's
blood streams there's there's a chemical
warfare happening right now that is
affecting not just the human body but
the human mind and I think this is why a
lot of people have been going crazy this
is why I think there's more homelessness
uh there's a bigger homelessness problem
out there than there was before which is
usually linked to a mental health crisis
I think right now we are going through
some kind of medical intervention that
that is not natural that is destroying
human life on this planet but but Luke
a great man once said there are too many
people on this planet and uh that was
Bill Gates By the way and um uh don't
you think he's right there are too many
people Luke absolutely not I think uh
what Elon Musk uh has been talking about
to the opposite problem occurring
especially in a few decades from now is
the real problem because it's actually
backed by science it's actually backed
by data that is not paid and bought for
by Bill Gates and it's highlighting a
huge crisis of civilization that's going
to be hitting our way especially in the
western world where people aren't making
children one because people can't
sometimes because people don't want to
because they've been brainwashed and
propagandized not to to me in my
personal opinion we are going through a
population Reduction Program a lot of
people don't know about it a lot of
people are not aware of it a lot of
people are just living their lives
trusting the authorities and they're
being chemically attacked and castrated
in a way that's going to stop them from
reproducing but you think it's on
purpose absolutely I think I think
there's two motives here one is profit
and incent and I think the other one is
deliberate and I think both are playing
a part here I think there's a few people
that are saying too many people in this
world we have to intervene we have to
incentivize the use of GMOs we have to
incentivize the use of glacify we have
to incentivize the use of high fructose
corn syrup yeah real quick there are
people like Bill Gates who have publicly
stated there are too many people and we
have to take action absolutely now
beyond that you know there's there's
corporations that are incentivized to do
this because then big Industries like
corn high fructose corn syrup and
glycophate are subsidized and of course
given to these corporations for very
cheap they of course give it out to the
general public and whether it's seed
oils high sugar or or just the the
chemicals that are banned in so many
other countries we give it to our
children the diet that our children are
given is absolutely horrendous it's
leaving to brain defects and it's
leaving towards a destroyed civilization
that of course won't be able to get up
from its feet because it's being
bombarded with poisons I will add this
though but like because I agree 100 with
you're saying that it is the derivative
of you know of a of something chemical
but all would also add that it's
something derivative of propaganda which
is another word that you use
um we were talking before the show you
use the word choice you know what I'm
saying and people think that people
choosing to eat bad food right yeah
exactly and so it's like yeah it is
something to do with choice but that
choice is part and parcel of propaganda
people are kind of reacting to a certain
pattern of stimuli that's propagandized
to them by certain movements and certain
things that happen in a very pervasive
and inundated way you know second wave
feminism had a very uh negative effect
on how we move as a society you know I
mean going into the uh the you know 21st
century but there's two other layers
here that I think are important to
understand Beyond just propaganda one is
that the food is engineered to be
chemically addictive so when you have it
it literally is engineered to hit the
pleasure centers in your mind so you
become addicted to the sugar to the seed
oils another aspect to really understand
here is that it's also cheap and readily
available because it's subsidized by big
industries that have bought off
politicians that are going along with
this agenda and don't even know that
they're doing it yeah so we as people
are being led in the way that we that
they think we should go exactly you know
what I've been hearing a lot we've been
talking about this quite a bit over here
there are a bunch of people we know
who came from other countries or visited
other countries when they came to
America they gained weight yeah and they
all said the same thing like there's
like four or five people we have
anecdotally who have been like I eat the
exact same food and dinner the same
schedule I've always done but when I
came to America I started getting
gaining a bunch of weight and then I'm
like nah maybe it's like you think
you're eating the same amount like
you you would order rice and beans and
chicken then you come to America but the
plates ten times bigger maybe that's
what's happening but they insist they're
like that's not true like I I will make
the food myself it's the same food and
then we had a couple people that moved
back like friends of ours and then the
weight was gone so I'm wondering uh you
know Ian often thinks it's the bromine I
don't know about brominated wheat flour
and stuff like that I don't know about
that I don't know what specific chemical
or whatever there is they're putting
stuff or something like that
you know but something something in our
food maybe I have no idea yeah there's
there's a number of things and it's very
hard to put your your kind of uh finger
on it to directly because we're dealing
with so much bureaucracy we're dealing
with so much corruption the FDA has has
approved so many different chemicals
that are banned that you cannot give to
people in many different countries but
here in the United States it's it's okay
but there's a rushed experimental
therapy we're gonna Rush that through
that's perfectly safe and fine which is
absolutely crazy and and bewildering and
there's so many different aspects and so
many different layers we could get into
this but there's a lot of other speakers
and scientists that I think we should
maybe try to have on the show uh
carnivore or MD he's also a really good
uh smart medical doctor that presents a
lot of this information and data a lot
better than I do but I've just been
awakened to this because you know after
I you know I quit smoking cigarettes you
know I I started to see really bad
health effects after uh giving up
something that you know was really
really bad for me I was like what's
really going on here and it really put
me down a path where I had to research
this and once you start researching it
you go down a rabbit hole of holy cow
you go down the supermarket aisle and
you're loudly saying everything's here
poison everything here is trying to kill
me or hurt me in some kind of way and I
make a point to say that loudly every
time I'm in the Super Bowl hear me the
FDA is yet another you know because you
you mentioned the world you know
economic Forum so on and so forth I
would include in and amongst that the
FDA so yes absolutely corrupted
organization hijacked by multinational
corporations that are not looking out
for your best interest that are
literally poisoning you with so many
chemicals that that yet again illegal in
so many places legally I saw yes I saw
uh uh I think it yeah it was yesterday
yesterday we went down to the Blue Ridge
Rock Fest it was really really awesome
and uh driving around Danville Virginia
I saw an OG Pizza Hut an original Pizza
Hut building it's like man I haven't
seen one of those in a long time Jack
basobic talks about him yeah with the
weird Little Red Roof or anything like
that we were thinking about going there
we ultimately didn't go there and I was
reminded of that story Jack masobic
tells where he went to a Pizza Hut
bringing his kids because he wanted them
to have the experience he had when he
was a kid and then realizing like what
he had is gone and it was disgusting and
falling apart and now Pizza tends to be
just like a strip mall store with a
delivery only
but I bring this up because you know
I remember we had a we had Papa John on
the show yeah and you know he likes to
say better ingredients better Pizza Papa
John's well he's not there anymore they
went woke and got broke and then kicked
him out but uh but he talks about how
you know they actually use better
ingredients so I looked it up sure
enough Papa John's ingredients are like
basic the the cro the dough is like
flower water yeast and I was like Wow
and the cheese is like skim milk and I'm
like okay and the sauce is like Roma
tomatoes or whatever and sugar and then
I was like okay well that's really
impressive and then I look up Pizza Hut
I think Pizza puts Splenda in their
crust they sweetened their crust with
artificial sweetener I could be wrong
it's been a while since I looked it up
but that was like wow they really do
want everything to be sweeter and that's
gross and then Domino's I think I think
they're not they don't put like
sweetener like that in there but their
ingredients is like a whole bunch of
weird chemicals that you don't
understand and it's crazy when you
realize
most of the big fast food chains except
for Papa John's
um it's it's weird chemicals you're
eating you can't you can't produce I'm
sorry you can't pronounce yet you don't
care that you're eating it that to me is
just weird yeah and your body can't
break it down so your body is in a
constant state of inflammation that it
can't deal with and when it's inflamed
it has a hard time processing and
working well and if your gut's not
working well your brain is not working
well since your brain is dependent on
the chemicals produced in your gut and I
think a lot of this is deliberate
because if you could destroy someone's
Health if you could destroy someone's
sanity and mental Clarity you could more
easily enslave them because if you have
them in a pathetic fat State you have
them in a state where they don't respect
themselves and if you don't respect
yourself you're not going to stand up
for yourself and therefore you're a lot
easier to squash you're a lot easier to
control you're a lot easier to
manipulate and I think there's a big
agenda happening and this is my own
personal opinion that this is all
engineered and planted and created in a
way specifically to hurt us in the in
the worst possible way think Luke is
right about you know and people are fat
and slow and and tired they're easier to
control and that's why I gave Luke a box
of cookies today you did two of them
I looked at that I'm like you're trying
to get me fat the seconds I saw that we
have these special cookies that very
fancy and they're fudge dipped birthday
cake Oreos
sprinkles and it says step on snack and
find out um they look incredible they
look they're amazingly like it's like
just they just look so good I haven't
had one it's a drug it really is yes you
eat one and then you know you want to
eat more but one cookie is 130 calories
wow one cookie and they're and they're
little Oreos
that's that's that's food I guess man I
gotta tell you when the apocalypse
happens survivalists are going to be
like yes like this one last months
you probably eat a couple of them and
then uh you just you gotta work your
energy yeah yeah quick energy I guess
until you until you crash and burn
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there